hello in this special edition of your
biscuits we just wanted to let you know
up top and unequivocally how much we
love our children love spending time
with them and how much we welcome them
into all not all aspects of our lives
but all the appropriate aspects of our
lives I'm making this weird it'll make
more sense when we get into the episode
because this is at the top of the
episode it's not right now in the middle
where I'm actually saying it to clarify
we love them we just don't always like
them is that does that
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're gonna get cooking
like it's I guess the heat of summer
talking about summertime summertime some
some summertime we're gonna pay for that
we didn't license it's a summer I made
that song up oh yeah different thing
that's a legal thing it's illegal to
make that claim oh gosh you know what we
are gonna be talking about summer
answering some summer related questions
talking a little bit about what we're
doing this summer well what we've done
in past summers I think yeah one of the
things I'm doing this summer is a raise
my mic up about an inch
I get your your back is more arched in
like an odd kind of a way well I tend to
hunch I've hunted most of my life you
know I like to seem normal
I'm not but I like to seem normal I
could lend in and so I tend to bring
myself down but you know what the Summer
2018 man I'm going up an inch got our
arch that watch that back is this what
it feels like to be you he if I had good
posture yeah I mean my nipples are gonna
pop them and frickin tell it tell said
tell a shirt
tell us your tell us shirt what what
were you combining well because I have a
television character on my t-shirt no
you don't yeah cotton candy Randy I use
television in the broad sense this was
happening right now is television you
tell me what
for those of you who are watching what
part of what's happening right now is
not television what every part break it
down it's vision and it's talent well
it's the this show is more of a is more
of a teleplay well it's a radio play who
cares we're talking about summer summer
and yeah you're already hunting get you
just get you lower your money back down
no we're in the middle of a summer that
has been well or get I mean or
orchestrated it's been both that's what
I said orchestrated you used a G oh
you're saying I say orchestrated wrong
it's orchestrated but it's cool I mean
both well orchestrated I mean as you
notice I've said it many times and I
haven't changed it at all because I'm
I'm emphatically staking my claim what
do you call a group of people playing
instruments an orchestra no that's a
group of people playing and fans who are
donating their organs and organ
that's when an orchestra plays - like
for people's organs like what do you
think is that it's like a fundraiser for
organs what do you call a group of or
only organs are being played like pipe
organs what do you call a group of trees
that are intentionally planted in rows
and then they grow fruit tree farm like
peaches
or Apple Oh an ordered right an ordered
last summer we were talking about this
summer it's weird how that happened we
were talking about how what we wanted
the summer of 2018 to be like in the
midst of 2017 we didn't want it to be
like 2017 this would be different summer
is different than a summer we've had in
a long time
mission accomplished man we're we're
accomplishing a mission for the past two
summers we we we worked on good mythical
morning and shot it in such a way
and kind of planned breaks I can't two
summers ago we didn't do good mythical
summer last summer's when we did give
number with Monday Wednesday and then
Friday guess host so that we could Bank
episodes and then film buddy system
season one two summers ago season two
last summer and we just catapulted
ourselves out of our weekly routine of
filming good mythical morning into just
a very aggressive production schedule
with making buddy system a reality well
and while we were filming buddy system
we were preparing for two different
things we were preparing for our tour
which was right on the heels of buddy
system mm-hmm and we were also preparing
for the expanded version of good
mythical morning and like interviewing
people and like we wouldn't even eat
lunch while we were shooting buddy
system we would like have interviews it
was and I guess we were doing this show
and I think talking about it some I mean
laughs yeah yeah well I mean I think we
were talking about how man I don't know
this is just crazy well and we talk go
back and listen to that and then that'll
make us appreciate it even more because
you know as we as we try to develop this
discipline of stopping and celebrating
we had the crew host the podcast that's
right that's what we did in order to to
gain some time to do the other stuff
you're trying to orchestrate the habit
we were orchestrating like you wouldn't
have stopping and celebrating so I kind
of feel like I want to assess whether
whether we're doing that and I think you
already have said that we are I mean
this summer is it's a lot it's a lot
more laid back for us which is so great
I mean we said we want to I want to plan
a vacation that's more than a week and
let's go to Australia and then that was
kind of the start of okay there's some
work involved we're gonna do some tour
of mythicality stops in in Australia but
then the vast majority of the time we're
gonna we're gonna have our families
there we're gonna be in vacation mode at
the end of July it's gonna be I can't
wait
don't listen don't build it up too much
I don't he has the vacation build-up
syndrome is something that I suffer from
you brought most people suffer from it
VBS yeah yeah it's not vacation bible
school anymore
no it's vacation build-up in rome and
it's you you think that it's going to be
great you begin measuring everything
according to when you're going to be on
vacation and then you begin to think
I'll be happy when I'm on vacation then
you inevitably get on vacation it takes
you several days to adjust to being on
vacation and then you have this extended
period of like not quite met
expectations and then the next thing you
know you're going back home and then
you're looking forward to the next
weekend you can't let that happen can't
let it you have to think it's going to
suck it's gonna suck when we go to
Australia it's gonna be the worst time
ever now we're in the perfect place
gonna be and it's gonna be your fault
it's gonna be your fault
it can't be both of our faults and I
said it was yours well it could be your
fault for me and my fault for you
deal yeah well hold on let's just make
it the kids fault they'll be there yeah
well they're gonna they're gonna
definitely be there I guess miserable we
shouldn't yeah take them what are we
thinking but too late I mean can we
resell the tickets and like a some sort
of a like some sort of scalping
situation what can we scalp plane
tickets no that is that you have to be
it has it be the name that is attached
to the ticket true you can't even you
can't even if once you buy a ticket if
you want to just change the person like
if we decided that you know one of our
we wanted to take one of our kids
friends instead of one of our kids
because they like did something wrong
always a chance that will happen I
always tell my kids that I'd rather be
with their friends then you can't do
that the airline's make it very
difficult trust me I tried to replace my
kids with other kids many times last
minute before vacation we feel that way
but then we also love our kids dearly
and we're kind of joking okay kind of
I'm glad that we're bringing them at
least it'll be great but it's gonna be
good that involved it's gonna be
horrible
but I'm proud of us that we in our
commute back from filming buddy system
and we were just
commiserating about how exhausted we
were or like you know when next summer
is gonna be different and you know what
we had the discipline to follow through
and look it is different and so I just
wanted to assess haha how do you feel
I actually I felt a little lost honestly
I feel great like not having something
that I have to film basically every
single day I just kind of feel like oh
my gosh I'm well done with myself well
you said it was laid-back I but I want
to I want to I think and I'm not trying
to like I'm not trying to be like we are
working really hard we but we are
working what we're working on is
something that we haven't is we're
working on things in a way that we
haven't worked on anything in a while
probably since like six years seven
years ago yeah so since things kind of
got going once we moved to California
it's been one thing after the other and
and multiple things at a time usually
but we always kind of knew exactly what
the next thing was going to be and while
we are working on some things right now
that we can't yet talk about the main
thing that we're doing is we are
developing other ideas not what we've
always done is we've we've we've gotten
an opportunity to do something and then
we filled it with an idea but we're
actually sitting around talking about
all kinds of ideas and all kinds of
different outlets different media and
we're developing these ideas we're
actually talking about them developing
worlds developing characters fleshing
them out writing things up we're having
meetings to try to make some of those
things a reality but it's it's the
summer of like lining things up and just
throwing them at the wall and seeing if
something sticks and I don't mean I'm
having an incredible time but it is also
the kind of thing because it's not it's
all speculative so for me I tend to
overanalyze whether anything that we're
working on if it's
it's like if none of this amounts to
anything which I don't believe that and
I get excited about the things that we
talk about because it's such a mode that
we've usually just kind of crammed in
like if we're in the car going somewhere
and one of us you know I had this idea
and then it just kind of percolates a
little bit but having dedicated time to
just sit on a couch or then go to lunch
like we've gone to lunch we have left
this facility and we've gone to lunch
and then so a couple times when the food
was done more likely that was over what
lunch was done we should have gotten up
and left yeah I'm gonna get a I'm gonna
get a coffee
and stay here a little longer I feel
like an actor you know how like around
here in Los Angeles you see just Pete
all times of the day you just see people
sitting places drinking coffees yeah
these are actors good-looking people
that look like they should be actors and
I think that there are like commercials
and but they're not currently I'm not
currently on a commercial but I've I
make a buttload of money from like a
sherbert scoobert mercial Herbert
scoobert is my favorite brand of tennis
balls right have you tried the Newser
Burt's cube root tennis balls it's two
guys now with twice the bounce so they
eat for making their own sherbert tennis
rubber Herbert made a tennis ball that
was really bouncy hey I had like the
perfect bounce but then it it didn't
have the right texture and then
skippered he has a few Birds or scoobert
skier Burt skippers scoobert zur
Burton's gibart but yeah but I say
scoobert well you miss it you're
mispronouncing his name well it's an
orchestra it's written on the tennis
ball zoo Burt's Kerber skipper I think
it's spelled the same way how do you
spell secure bird hit s K I
ar-ar-ar-ar bi i RT Herbert Herbert
yes and thank you so now you're back
with your skirt zur Burton's gibart
that's how you say it and skinned Burt's
ball had the perfect fuzz on the outside
he had what they call skippered fuss
but it didn't have that sir Burt bounce
and then somebody I think it was Nancy
who's she
it's the CEO no she said let's bring you
two together in form and - it you're -
it these two oh you're talking about the
- a Taser burger Burt I'm talking about
the unhyphenated service Gerber this
whole time I've been talking about
bankrupt the unhyphenated ones the one
that was popular in the 70s moot point
oh sorry sir Burt stop this perfect
tennis ball and then they got this jerk
guy in Los Angeles like in the
commercials can't even serve properly
you read a set yeah yeah he's a good
talker though I could tell that he
didn't memorize his lines that he was
like reading them off a cue card yeah
who cares
but he's still getting resist he's
getting all the resist but when he's not
collected any and now he just he's coast
he's just drinking coffee he's sitting
down on us yeah
sipping a eating a crepe oka
and that was us for a little while I
thought I got a guy on Fairfax you're
talking about the guy that was in the
zubur skirt commercial on cooling I'm
talking about the guy that was in the
service corporate commercial unfair fact
is there two commercials I thought yeah
there is you're right but it I'm talkin
about the blonde guy oh you know what I
thought he was wearing away oh I thought
it was the same guy yeah why didn't they
use the same guy and just put a wig on
him well different markets right once
once for Maine and then once for the
rest of the continental United States
the wig does look like a mane like a
lion's mane it goes down on either side
it's kind of like you know what's that
headpiece that if a row wears a pharaoh
now you go tell me I was a pharaoh
you said it right Pharaoh it sounded
like Rhett like a bro let my people go
Pharaoh
his wig was shaped like what like a
pharaoh headpiece but it's hair of
course yeah I think it's Pharaoh Pharaoh
ha ha I mean I don't know you're
thinking of Pharrell the artist anyway
never kind of like that guy yeah we're
just like those sitting there drink
the waiter came by and was like okay are
you can I take your and we're like yeah
and you know what I'd like I'd like a
cappuccino I got a couple of teas I
doubled I double teed one day I got tea
and then I got another tea that's how
good I'm feeling a new bag or a new and
tire I don't at a new water new bag and
we're talking about ideas like this
would be a great television show this
will be a great movie No Limits yeah so
the chances that any of the stuff that
we're talking about right now actually
becomes a reality is actually is is
beside the point it's not slim but it
it's probably the next idea which is a
little unusual for us because again when
you when you do stuff on the Internet
even with the stuff that we've done with
YouTube like with buddy system we ended
up getting a show on YouTube bread
before anyone knew what the show was I
mean that's the that's you know it's the
truth that's how that's how it went down
it was like do you guys have an idea
like yeah we got an idea let's come up
with an idea buddy comedy scripted it's
gonna have musical elements and this is
uh this process in the pitch was
backwards which is kind of an exist
going through the more traditional
traditional process of you know talking
to gatekeepers about ideas it's a that's
right they won't even let us on studio
lot so we just talking to the guy who at
the gate yeah it's uh it's not me but
I'm really enjoying it I'm really
enjoying it even if I get any time I had
a lot in terms of because my personality
type I keep a running record of like
have I accomplished enough today do I
feel like I've earned the right to go to
bed tonight I think is something that
it's subcon
just for me so I have to make an active
decision kind of like what you're
talking about being on vacation there's
that transition period I'm still kind of
in that in terms of what our summer is
but well it's gonna be over before you
know it so you better start enjoying it
soon and it's gonna be your fault but I
do think that some of the ideas or these
I will lead to something
well of course while good mythical
morning continues to to go or to stay I
don't mean you know what I'm saying I
feel like whenever we talk about some of
that's not good mythical morning there's
a certain person that we need to
reassure that it's not gonna have a
negative impact on good mythical certain
person be reassured that good mythical
morning is not going anywhere you want
to talk you want to answer some summer
questions yeah we have summer questions
from you I think we'll get to I think
we'll get to many of those but first we
want to remind you that you can go over
to mythical dot store to meet all your
life needs your life need maybe a let's
talk about that shirt check it out
that's the back the front has a sort of
a version of the GMM logo the back has
that catchphrase that we always say at
the beginning of every show mm-hmm might
be the name of another show that we're
developing it could be it might be we
don't want to that shows up it
definitely is it shows up on the
weekends I think that's actually
launched a good my thing that's been
announced through some outlets yeah
there's going to be a set a Saturday was
some article and we didn't you know we
didn't announce it but I'm sorry if
that's how you heard about it but now
we're talking about it yes just casually
every Saturday when GMM comes back for
season 14 there's gonna be a show called
let's talk about that well we talked
about the show with Stevie I don't know
what it's gonna be
we've only started to talk about what it
might be and I'm pretty excited I'm very
excited I also have the car I'm really
excited not knowing what it's going to
be
even as we do it I think that's part of
the premise I'll just I'll go that far
I'm gonna know what's going on but link
won't uh this is the cuff you want to
know more about anything we're working
on just continue to read variety but
cotton candy rated t-shirt that says hi
daddy's also available mythical does
store and you may see this if you follow
the social media over the retin link
accounts and the mythical accounts if
you has tag if you take a picture of
yourself in some mythical apparel and
then you hashtag it with the word
mythical you may get featured on the
mythical account we're doing that now
follow mythical Instagram yeah okay okay
let's get to some questions some are
theme related help you guys out and then
maybe maybe reveal some things about
ourselves in the process razo res one my
friend and i have been talking about
having an adventurous summer because we
haven't we've always lived a boring life
oh well we want to do something exciting
and dangerous what are some new
experiences that my friend and I should
try while also not spending too much
money as we are college students
exciting and dangerous put this down no
right but you're almost blocking my shot
hold it right there for some reason when
you said exciting and dangerous the
first thing I thought about and I think
it's great advice is get a kayak you and
your friend eight get a kayak and go on
a go on a River excursion I'm talking
about like Rapids situations this is
2018 I think we should probably give a
disclaimer if you get a kayak and then
you end up injuring yourself or dying
because you're in a kayak but she said
dangerous you're the one who asked you
wanted dangerous activities well you're
not responsible for your kayaking okay
no we're not that being said you
definitely get a kayak cuz it's extreme
and dangerous when I was we did and I
was in middle school at the time that
our friend Ben talked us into getting
kayaks and I went to get a kayak from
some but I don't know where I bought it
but you're too big for a kayak I mean I
couldn't put it on a kayak is like put
it on a
I couldn't get I couldn't fight
especially where we were I couldn't find
a kayak that could fit me that had the
proper internal parts of a kayak so I
got an old-school kayak which is late
like a kayak let's clarify what internal
parts are there's like there's bladders
there's well not only that there's
places for your feet like your there's
there's places that your feet rest this
kayak did not have those things then
also there are the rotation the
floatation parts on the inside so we're
talking balloons inside of the front and
back of the kayak so that even if it
fills with water and it will when you
pop out of it and struggle to maintain
your life force it will not sink because
it's it's um it's it's filled with these
bladders well they're filled with air
not urine and my kayak did not have
these so what I did because it yours was
uses like a 19-7 it was very cold it was
a it was a covered top canoe it was like
a canoe that had a top on it but it had
a hole just just just for me so what I
ended up doing is first of all I
christened the USS Merle you painted
that on painted the USS Merle with the
stencil on the side and then I found in
my attic I found all this foam from like
the previous residents of my parents
house in the Attic there was just all
this like a box of pieces of foam like
yellow flexible foam okay like and I
took bunch of trash bags filled him up
with the foam tied him off double-bagged
him and just stuff them into the insides
of the kayak that was my floatation I
went to REI and Karie they had like a
bulletin board it said kayak for sale
and Durham I went to Durham and I bought
the mattador office some college student
from Duke University brought it back
nestled down in that thing had
floatation that had tubing where you'd
like you'd blow in a long straw and like
you would pump up the floatation
then I remember the first time I got it
it might had a bunch of smelled very
mildewy
yeah those Duke those Duke students have
a little do problem when I opened up the
floatation thing to blow more air into
it
the Duke college students air came out
Oh Duke air into my face ah Duke student
Duke undergraduate lung air and so it's
very it's a little smart pretentious
little pretentious like really hoping to
get into a good graduate program it's it
smells up a little bit of desperation
and also a lot of like pressure from
parents their entire lives right he in
yeah and he needed the money so it was
it was a lot of desperation coming out
of that bladder
yeah but man we took those things on the
river we would go down to our win' on
the river I mean how long of a trip was
that it was probably a 4-hour trip on
our kayaks that's yeah took how about
today a lot of that was just very slow
River yeah but there will be some very
intense Rapids right when you got to the
end in Erwin Denham capital of the world
he used to make a lot of jeans there
mm-hmm
and if you made it if you got to shore
there they would there would be people
men women children lots of children
would just it would just give Eugene's
it was just like when you land in Hawaii
and they give you leis they would just
they put jeans on you right remember
that yeah yeah and we and we that's why
we always went pantsless right while
kayaking cuz we knew if we got to or
when they give us the jeans and if we
didn't make it they just find this
floating dead in our undies so that's
your advice I mean it flood stage dive
definitely turned over there's times
when like you instead of kayaking around
trees you're going through the tops of
the trees in flood stage we did that so
stup it was it we did a lot of things
that our summers were filled with a lot
of things that danger not advisable
we're probably bout to get to another
one Shelby Austin what's your opinion on
water shoes for adults personally we
won't step into a body of water where I
can't see my feet in it without
them hashtag no shame well if there's
any way we can bring shame into the
equation I would love to do it right now
because I'm against water shooters it's
just like those didn't exist when when
when we were frolicking in the in the
water I mean in the river just to stay
in the river here we would um we would
wear our tennis shoes we would have
river tennis you had a pair of shoes
then it had had well a pair of shoes
that you had fully worn out on land that
now became river shoes and you would not
wear socks and then it would you just
lay some really tight and that is that
is difficult it's difficult to swim in
tennis shoes but you don't really have
to swim as much as just don't die if we
had only had water shoes if water shoes
hadn't been a thing we probably probably
would have worn them been wore duck
shoes like the rubber shoes that then
turn into leather at the top yeah he
wore those duck boots no sound like an
insulating layer in them too and now
they were like winter shoes but he wore
them all the time and you're warm in the
river yeah I don't know once those
things fill up with water it's like
we're in to liquid anchors crazy man
but the I mean fashion in terms of
fashion I know I've yet to see a person
look respectable in water shoes I will
say that when we did the Willett
slip-and-slide episode we needed some
grippy shoes and Daniel gave us those
they're not water socks they were they
had the individual toes but they were
like what are those things they're kind
of like I think they're a form of water
sock I felt a little self-conscious
wearing those but also it was kind of
neat so if you I think if you're gonna
do it these are not technically aqua
shoes water socks or whatever you call
them but if you get those like
individual toe shoes things you're gonna
look like a dummy but it's pretty cool
but I do I do think you shouldn't get
into a body of water if you're the one
wearing well you can't see your feet
barefoot water shoes is what those are
called Thank You Jacob for the
clarification
I don't think you should I do agree with
Shelby's assessment that you should not
get
to a body of water where you can't see
your feet without some sort of sort of
covering I mean I don't know how we we
never got hurt all the time that we
spent in the Cape Fear River with no
real you know this is a serious River
serious Rapids water moccasins no life
jackets we were walking across the rapid
swimming down the rapids and we had some
like technique that we developed we're
like you got to keep your feet forward
and keep your hands up which is true but
there's not just a lot of good fortune
that got us back and forth across that
river thousands of times and we found
getting into an yeah so in Belize Creek
there's that that that set of Rapids
there that we would spend most of our
time we knew like there was a secret
waterhole that was probably ten feet
deep even though everything around it
was like three feet deep we'd swim there
that was pretty cool but then we would
also go down the river further and not
all the way to erlan there was that
place that had the huge rocks and we
would swim there and then what they had
these places that we would call them
jacuzzis you know where the rapids would
kind of it would Eddy back on themselves
and basically the water would churn and
and dig a hole and if the if the river
was at the right level some rocks will
be exposed such that there was a lot of
water spilling into this hole and then
churning around and you one person could
fit in at a time and you could hold your
breath and go underwater remember and
put your head under the water the
waterfall and breathe over there well we
were doing that every after we graduated
college we went down to our win' and we
did that and remember you you got stuck
oh my foot got stun of your feet guts
that's up and that's how you died and it
was there was a panic situation because
we're in the middle of this river and
I'm like his foot is stuck and you
eventually got free this is crazy makes
me think I just read this news article
today there's a river in Arkansas where
apparently it's not uncommon in Arkansas
for sinkholes to open up in the riverbed
good
Lord and these people are like kayaking
or rafting so like the river just
disappears like no no sinkhole in the
middle of the river formed a whirlpool
that started taking someone down and a
guy saved people but then the guy who
saves people went down and died like
this happened yesterday I I did I saw
this like the headliner and read too
many of the details maybe he'll pop up
maybe he's not dead I I doubt that's
gonna happen yeah sinkhole
yeah but we never saw any other
sinkholes are jerks man no warning like
email or something just send a warning
there's a there's a ramp onto the
highway and I noticed the other day it
said it's like a construction ramp and
it says this ramp will be closed
intermittently between February 2017 and
March 2018 and of course it's after Park
itse that's a big swath of time and when
we and and we're beyond it and the sign
is still up and by the way they're still
closing that ramp sometimes
intermittently intermittently I mean but
I think they should take the sign down
well they should adjust the size I got
one
Brianna Schmid what do you do she did
what do you and your wives do to keep
the kids from bickering all summer good
question she says we have a pool a
trampoline and an Xbox welcome okay you
go Briana you got it we got all that
stuff to keep them entertained but they
still managed to drive each other and me
emphasis on me nuts fighting over the
smallest things they are ten six and
three all girls oh gosh well first of
all minor eight thirteen and fifteen and
it don't stop so don't get your hopes up
that the bickering over the smallest
things is gonna stop no I love my kids I
know we've already laid it into him at
the top
but well what we we have the Scott have
a trampoline we have discovered no I
would have thought maybe that was the
thing but be honest saying it's not I've
had I've had all of these things at some
point in my life currently have a pool
and an xbox had a trampoline
well you go at my am I in my own in my
past
you also have an Xbox in a pool but you
but I'm not talking about it talking
about it I also have an Instagram
account this is a point I'm just trying
to use it I'm just trying to relate to
Brianna here so I can say that I feel
qualified to answer this question we
have discovered the wonders of summer
camp we heard about you people just yeah
yeah we heard about these people who are
like we send our kids off for a month
we're like what a month there's like six
weeks and then somebody else too much
like they were dating and they began
bidding on how long yeah sometimes they
come back we don't quite where were
their names and we're like what this
that's a long time and most of them were
like in or northeast northeast
apparently it's a northeast thing north
northeastern people don't like their
kids northeastern people like their kids
less than we like our kids apparently
and this goes back to when we were you
know if we lived in the Northeast we
would have gone to these camps for we
would have it's like boarding school
yeah but everybody loves it the kids
love it and need I have to assume the
adults love it it's a win-win I mean it
might hurt the wallet so the wallet does
but if you've already got a pool
trampoline in an Xbox it shouldn't be a
problem
[Music]
[Laughter]
so yeah rez exactly right we started we
started like we get put our heads
cuz for us camps we're just you know
there was one summer between I don't
know when it was I we could figure it
out but that ubiquitous photo of the two
of us as kids with the purple girl
shirts on the matching shirts standing
in front of rets dad's Dodge Dynasty
that was taken in the parking lot the
zoo the summer between sixth and seventh
grade maybe between fifth and sixth
definitely one of those two seams right
that was taken in the zoo parking lot
where we had just purchased the t-shirts
after your dad had picked us up from
spending a week in the mountains of
North Carolina at Camp Carraway I wonder
if is still there he's gotta be still be
there we did that once and we never went
back
well I wanted to go back but because you
puckered up and didn't take a crap the
entire week and had a horrible
experience we didn't go back cuz I
didn't want I wasn't gonna go back by
myself well at night you had a totally
dark it was great man it was and in the
day it would be light but but but it was
great like that we went on hikes we
spent we went we took that one hike out
into the middle of nowhere and like
slept at this old abandoned camp he was
dark there too we roasted marshmallows
they did these crazy like activities at
night with bonfires I mean very
dangerous I remember loving every part
of it but every time I would check in
with you you would just have this like
pained look on your face like nothing
was going well it was quite literally
out of my comfort zone I mean when you
line up to take showers and then they
got like stop watches and they're like
everybody just gets a couple of minutes
that was uncomfortable that was
uncomfortable and it's a cold shower and
then you're like if you were gonna poop
somebody could walk right by and see you
I don't think that's why you didn't poop
I mean I I'm body knew I didn't poop as
much as normal whatever I had when I
arrived at camp my body knew to keep it
cuz it didn't know what else it was
gonna get well but it kept getting camp
food the rest of the time did you were
you not eating it maybe not maybe not
Carraway still open so you did
eventually put I'm sorry hold on but
then hold on you didn't poop and then we
went to the zoo did you poop with the
zoo I'm sure the animals did it would be
hard to watch to not poop that long
go see animal and they're pooping left
and right it's like they're taunting
because it makes me feel different about
that picture of us with a gorilla shirts
on to know that you're holding a seven
days worth of crap in your large
intestine but the expression on your
face is so happy I'm very so happy to be
at the zoo released man yeah you had not
experienced that relief you took a crap
at the zoo there's no way that's I just
crapped a seven day log face yeah it
really is you know it's an it's a look
of relief and all I got is this purple
t-shirt that's why the t-shirt should
have said so we're sending our kids to
summer camp now first of all Locke is
gonna be doing the basketball thing most
of the most of the summer
scheppers not Shepherds not going away
to a sleepaway camp he's going to act
like a day camp but he but the thing is
every other day for like five it's five
what he's gonna be doing a lot by
himself but you're actually doing it
Lando's not going to any sleep amps but
Lincoln is going because he went for one
week last summer with a friend to a
sleepaway camp in Michigan actually
because that's where his friend was
already going and had been going this
year he's going with another friend for
two weeks
most of the camps they sell it really
hard on the website so well the first
week you really gotta stay for two weeks
if you're gonna make the best of it and
I'm like you ain't got to talk me into
it I mean cuz I'm really concerned about
we got a lot of questions from from you
guys in responding to our post about the
boredom you know if you're not working
over the summer you're freaking what are
you gonna do when the when the when the
Xbox gets old and the trampoline falls
through and your your pool gets stagnant
not you gonna you're just gonna be
filter you're just gonna be bored so
he's going away for for two weeks Lily's
going away for for one week to another
camp
I mean you drop a load on this stuff I
don't mean to bring that back up
what we'll see are you preparing for
that though they are related to you I
are you well it's funny to tell him the
story the other night where when your
parents were in town and we took them
all out to dinner right and like
Rhett's parents and my mom and her
husband Luis who yes he's technically my
stepdad but I don't call him that
he calls you his son-in-law does he yeah
he did that I mean he did that it is
employing the best is so sweet it's
technically accurate well it's
technically incorrect Oh
I mean maybe you are his son-in-law but
that's not typically what sort of all
means yeah here his step step son is is
accurate yeah son-in-law I don't call
him father-in-law I just call him
because that would mom direct you could
say stepdad would be I don't say stepdad
either okay I say my mom's husband okay
that's one way to it stepdad just
shorter way to it I mean when he arrived
I did give him a hug and when he left I
gave him another hug okay I know what
you're getting at though they're sitting
down there talking and then it's it's
Kristi and Jesse and then me and you and
so like you know on long tables it's
like everybody we're just kind of
talking in pairs like the two of us are
talking to our wives or talking to each
other and then our kids are down at
the-- at the other end of the table yeah
so you didn't hear apparently they were
talking about what we're talking about
now about the kids going to summer camp
and then you you catch one of the
conversation you're like you tell you
told them what we just talked about
you're like well when Lincoln I went to
summer camp linked it and crap the whole
week and the table just erupted and I
was like I said well I mean it's funny
but it's not that funny and then they
were like Kristy was just telling us
that when she went to summer camp as a
kid she didn't crap the whole time she
was there okay this okay this is a
serious problem so we're super
compatible you're taking a very high
constipation potential into these summer
camps with your kids I you know listen I
think that I mean
you gotta sensitives that that's the key
to marriage right there first of all
let's just focus on the positive for a
second but yeah genetically speaking
we're setting up our kids high
propensity for a world a lower GI hurt
in the in the coming weeks what should i
how do you prepare your kids for that
just for the next few days kids you're
just gonna take a dump in the backyard
yep that's why not to do it and you're
gonna have to watch each other yeah I
like that another thing you could do is
you could begin to slowly transform your
home environment into a camp environment
you could begin acting like a camp
counselor you could begin decorating
their room a little bit differently and
if they can learn how to crap in that
environment then they'll just carry it
right through to the summer camp I mean
I didn't dislike camp and I'm really
glad that I'm sure they're gonna enjoy
it and I'm sure they'll poop at
appropriate times I don't think I have
to go through this but all of the all of
the rituals of camp are pretty cool so I
hope that the camps they're going to
have those like rituals I think they all
do like an even camp Carraway it was
like first night yeah they uh I don't
remember the details camp counselors
like did some sort of performance and
the guys sing a song I thought they were
so cool moon pies and grapes Oh moon
pies and grapes oh the best song ever I
don't know the guy was so cool he had a
beard back when it wasn't cool to have a
beer right he was so ahead of his time
singing a song about moon pies and
grapes of course my wife went to
Meredith College an all-girls school
which was basically summer camp
year-round they had because they had all
types of rituals that they would do at
this thing corn husking and we would go
to her remember because I was I started
dating her and I would drag you to this
stuff I mean I made the magic of going
one year she had her rituals and stuff
they would hide the baton
there was a baton they still hadn't the
baton there and it was like this
sometimes they hide it under the bridge
the senior what like what is under the
bridge over the lake yes I think I'm
gonna get this all wrong but I'm just
gonna say it this way I think it was a
senior class that would hide the baton
and then all all year the junior class
liked their job was to find it
that's pretty cool right totally summer
camp stuff this is a college campus we
should had a baton around here well you
know chase put that picture of himself
at our office to cover up the hole where
it's the fire valve and it like if you
want if if like the sprinklers are going
off in this place you want to scramble
to turn them off or something you got to
punch through chases face grab a bow
he's obstructed the fire came through
here we'd be signifier Kodaka Spade
the level of a fire marshal fine and
then I'm I'm you found it within a day
though cuz it was next to your desk he
was like oh you found it I was like yeah
I found it I know where everything is
down to the millimeter in my office you
can't change anything I may not know it
I'm like but we moved it see if you can
find it it's somewhere else in the
office see if you can find it a few days
later I was like have you found it he's
like now I haven't found her yet another
day later I'm like you know you see him
passing like you found it you found your
picture it's like no I'm not really
looking up like you're looking he's like
I haven't found it I hadn't moved it
that was the joke I was like maybe you
should look at my office and then he
comes up he's I he's in the same place
gotcha it's not in the same place
anymore but I really got him that sky
you do it we should do a but time follow
him on Instagram he's sky douve what a
what a weirdo I'll brew bishop what's
the best way to even out a farmer's tan
I'm embarrassed to look like Neapolitan
ice cream I wanted to answer this
question because I recently saw myself
in the mirror and realized that don't
make a habit of looking at that I'm
working the farmer's tan too
I was it was really setting in right
here yeah you're talking right at the at
the at the traps I saw myself neck let
saw myself in the gym and because it
mirrors everywhere in the in the in the
locker room okay and I don't really see
my back very often you know it's not a
view that I take in very
I just doc yeah cuz you gotta have like
it it's gotta be like oh I'm a - mirror
mirror on a mirror and I'm not
interested in my back and maybe I should
be but I I noticed a very distinct line
forming okay and I was like I gotta do
something about this and so you know I
get up and I do the stretching in the
morning with the barber she gets on my
chest and we have the ritual you decided
to do that outside I was like I'm gonna
do Sun stretching that's cool that
sounds totally la and you sign people up
for an airbnb experience
calm enjoy some stretching with mr.
McCall Klaus it was on Saturday because
typically I'm up too early for there to
be Sun that could actually change your
farmer's tan not this summer man we are
laid-back but on Saturday you know I got
up and I had breakfast with the family
and then we're hanging out and then it
gets to be about 10 o'clock that's when
you start getting into like where the
sun's rays can have an impact and I went
out there and just a pair of sweatpants
not interested in getting my tan on my
legs and a Sun stretched for a good you
know 25 minutes or so I know how they
are bird jumps on you you'd have a
Barbara outline on your back which could
be cool actually
she'd have to stay very very still sit
down lay down but I think I got can you
see it look away a little bit more I
still see it a little bit but it's it's
not that pronounced like fading my
father-in-law has a tent he always wear
shorts he does a lot of grass mowing are
you better tell me you know where your
father-in-law's tan lines are is this
your father-in-law or your step there
because I never know with you which one
I don't call Lewis either man I call him
my mom's husband okay so this is your
wife's father yeah this is my your
father your actual father-in-law got it
Bobby Bobby he'll come in the house take
his shoes and socks off and get in his
recliner and let me tell you his feet
and ankles he wears like sucks that come
over as an ankle it's it's never seen
that it's net
seeing this direct sign right and it
shut his butt his legs are really tan
because he like fishes and he's outside
and he's mowing grass and he always
wears the same pair of socks yeah
no flip-flops no wouldn't be caught dead
in a barefoot it's it's like it's like a
Frankenstein situation but it's like he
still got socks on it's like they
attached a Caucasians foot do it well to
a Tanner yeah I was like we're not going
to get in a race where we stoop where
are you going with this way I don't know
he just super white man yeah is his his
his on Sun skin I'll just say like a
very white like it like us like a
Swedish foot to a to a Los Angeles
surfer dude leg okay that died work so
that's I don't know I'm in hot water
you want another question hit me Emily
Polinsky well I like to say that name
pop linski ironically you're
mispronouncing it but go ahead
that famously bad zeppelins CLE I won
ski I think we're done with the
pronunciation I've never I've never done
with it I'm done with it I'm not what oh
I wasn't trying to be funny I was just
be I was admiring I can't orga
straightaway for us to be done with it
I was just admiring the way that it
rolls off the tongue hi rhett and Link
what are some fun outside games that
don't involve a lot of physical activity
I love enjoying the nice weather but I'm
pregnant and get out of breath easily
but also want to have fun with the
energized seven-year-old we have please
all thank you he's got a seven year old
and another one on the way he's really
you spacing them out but congratulations
my advice is just to get it over with
and we're so cynical about the kids in
this episode let's put them let's put a
warning at the top yeah we love children
I bet just let's just put like the first
thing people are gonna hear I'll do it
now okay we'll put this at the top hello
and this special edition of your
biscuits we just wanted to let you know
up top and unequivocally how much we
love our children love spending time
with them and how much
we welcome them into all not all aspects
of our lives but all the appropriate
aspects of our lives I'm making this
weird it'll make more sense when we get
into the episode because this is at the
top of the episode it's not right now in
the middle where I'm actually saying it
to clarify we love them we just don't
always like them is that does that I
don't know what the Boop is like the I
think I just made it worse well I didn't
make it great
I think be real I actually like hanging
out with him it's just after a while
they need to do their own thing we still
at the top of the episode don't need to
Boop again no no congratulations on on
the pregnancy but warning that leads to
a child when you say get it over with
what do you mean go ahead and induce
labor no I meant no I said I usually
give advice to like plump your kids
together to get the whole process of
like child rearing over with and like a
clump yeah again and we've already been
through this how you shouldn't be giving
family planning advice to people and I'm
not we in fact it cut that out
is that another she has a son edit joke
she's pregnant and she has a seven year
old and you took your telling her to
squish it closer together I've seen
impossible no I'm not advising her she
all she's listening to me all she's
asking is how to what you should be
doing for exercise exercising fun play
fetch outside game with the
seven-year-old it's pretty obvious I
mean I think don't call it fetch but
everyone's gonna know it's fetch you sit
down with something the seven-year-old
likes and you throw it and then if that
many times you think that'll work they
bring it up humanist that's not a dog
it's a good experiment experiment
typically all the times that I play they
can fetch though no but when I've played
fetch with seven-year-old it's worked
the first time
yet it's not a two-year-old the second
time they're like what No so then what a
show you and I think at that points when
she should play cornhole which is what I
was trying to get to Oh Cornell because
cornhole is close contact cornhole a lot
of fun you don't want thirty feet though
you can eat and drink while you're doing
it it
low exertion but the competition can get
incredibly tense I just recommend
cornhole I mean if you got a pool Xbox
and a what's the other thing there's a
younger age group pool if you properly
clumped your children together you could
have played fetch but you can't do that
with seven year old that's an excellent
point
lisa-marie brew asks what is the best
thing to bring to a barbecue I don't
understand the question
oh gosh oh gosh Lisa your name is Lisa
Marie which is commendable but the fact
that your name is Lisa Marie and you're
still using the term barbecue as if it's
an event that you go to I'm gonna have
to take this opportunity to correct you
barbecue is not an event it isn't a
place you go it is also not the device
that you cook hamburgers and hot dogs on
it is also not a verb it isn't something
you do to meet barbecue is a noun and it
only refers to meat that is prepared in
a very special way that varies from
region to region mostly around the
southern United States how many times do
we have to say this we have not said it
enough you can't say it enough I mean at
the day we have to not say it is the day
we're in heaven and if that and if and
if that if if that means that everyone
on earth understands then the heaven on
earth in the side okay so we I said that
I don't want to drag on about that so
let's just I'll rephrase I'm just free s
Equestria tree ask the question Lisa
Marie southern first name the southern
heart to go along with it her last name
is brew for goodness sakes brewed Lisa
Marie brew best name ever what is the
best thing to bring to a cookout okay
now oh you mean a place where you'll be
you'll be cooking things yeah outside
you cooking out you're cooking it out
the answer is exotic sausages whoa okay
hey hey get some sideways looks okay
here's the thing people are gonna bring
burgers you mean exotically shaped no no
people this is I feel strongly about
this answer exotic now it may depend on
what you're trying to accomplish but if
you're trying to have a good time
eat some good food and score some points
you know get noticed a little bit you
don't want to bring hamburgers or hot
dogs you want to bring exotic sausages
if you're the guy who breaks out the
ostrich sausages everybody is gonna be
talking to you you know if you while
you're eating they're gonna be talking
to you about the exotic ostrich sausage
while you're eating what they brought to
the cook no no no no I get it
every single person try my ostrich
sausage and hey you might want to trade
these you wanna let me get a little bit
of that I don't think a girl has first
of all if cow you would enjoy it I mean
you're a very picky man but here's the
thing about all we're talking about
starting a conversation here making
friends it's you carrying ostrich
sausages kangaroo sausages oh no I'm
probably getting into like endangered
species at some point appropriately
raised exotic sausages not illegal trade
what's gonna happen is people are gonna
want to try it and you bring enough for
everybody to try it and next thing you
know people are like oh link ostrich
sausage man and there's a lot of work
out what I want to be known for there's
a lot of worse things to be known for
other than ostrich sausage man let me
tell you right now my answer was deviled
eggs okay I mean it's uh hey I'm
assuming with cookouts that like they
got like the meats covered but if it's
bring your own meat okay I'll go with
you because that's it it's it's a it's a
fun little thing that you're doing here
for everybody everybody guess it tastes
a little bit uh yep
but deviled eggs especially in a cookout
environment are perfect because they're
room temperature or
you go to a restaurant you order a
deviled egg it's gonna come they've made
it a long time ago and it's been
refrigerated and that's sometimes not
always that's not good the best place to
eat a deviled egg is is when aunt
Lucinda pulls the saran wrap off a plate
or two of her homemade deviled eggs
does she make that noise or does the
plastic metal plastic does it it kisses
the reminder okay I love deviled eggs
the yellow if you brought deviled eggs
to a cookout I'd be happier than if you
brought ostrich sausages here's the
problem with deviled eggs
the next day fart sees somebody gets
sick Oh somebody do people get sick
they're gonna even if who they're gonna
blame who are they gonna blame they're
gonna blame old egg man the devil if you
bring deviled eggs to something 'evil
and anybody whose eggs the blame falls
on you today I mean you got Eddie over
there yeah cooking the the chicken
breast and not cooking it all the way
into all the way to the bone what
internal temperature is sausage for
witness ostrich does it need to be
nobody knows if they're still gonna
blame deviled eggs Katy Katy Ritchie her
name is actually Kate Ritchie she's got
a Jeep I I see that huh sounds like
we're having a sexist reaction look a
female can't hold a Jeep well we were
doing no well then why were we saying I
was like that's cool it's because every
other icon on here is just somebody's
face there's a jeep you're sexist for
thinking we had a sexist reaction that's
true but I'm not sexist I didn't want to
say that yeah you're not helping Kate
Ritchie
I'm going on vacation with my best
friend near the end of summer okay cool
what should we do during the 12 hour car
ride to make it extra enjoyable hmm well
you I mean you've picked your best
friend so you got a good compadre for
this thing I mean it took an hour and a
half to drive and pick up my mom and my
stepdad my her spouse her husband and I
took Lando with me because I liked
hanging out with him because I love all
my children yeah and I look for any
opportunity hanging out with any of plus
I needed to legally drive in the carpool
lane and I was like shut up you're only
here so I can drive in the carpool lane
no I didn't say that because the whole
he was like dad let's play the alphabet
game so it's you're looking around I'm
just brainstorming here for us I mean it
literally for an hour and a half we
played two games I'm just gonna pitch
these I don't think this is what they
should play but I think it might be the
start of something that they can do
you'd look for a word that started with
the letter that you were on so I have a
so I'm like Oh allagash Lane and then he
has B and he has to find a be in signage
I understand ours oh you do and then we
played another game where it was still
the alphabet but it was you say your
name you say your best friend's name you
say your favorite food and you say where
you're from so if it was G be like hi my
name is Gary my best friend's name is
Gertrude my favorite food is Galapagos
turtles and that's real but no I'm from
the Galapagos Islands and my favorite
food is jelly how about grapes grape
jelly
we had a lot of fun with that
eating Turtles I mean that got us an
hour and a half
what okay no books on tape the overlap
between Lando and my
books on tape taste is not okay all
right there's no the Venn diagram looks
like two tires on a truck I don't think
that's gonna get 12 hours so I do think
though you can play that game for a
while about as long as you can play
fetch with a 77 year old human my vise
sucks today
no no well I think that one of the
things a was advice I said we're
beginning a brainstorming okay well now
you said well since neither one of those
nine you know I've led I'll add to it I
just find I just don't think they're
gonna take the whole trip have to yes
and it this is not improv no I think
you're gonna I don't even like those
people I think you're gonna agree with
my suggestion rest stops are really
underrated you know I'm saying let's put
things into perspective here you're
already paying for them you know what
I'm saying
oh they're there hours there they're
there the community's made citizens
there the public there the rest locale
for any citizen and have you been to
where lately where anything goes
have you listened rest time I don't got
a bad bad rap you know this is how it
goes I'm a rest stop I'm at the side of
the road you're driving real fast and
then you pull in slow when you stop you
get out you go to the bathroom you see a
weird dude by the trashcan you can run
back to your car and you leave X look as
you can as quick as you can okay
you don't agree I thought you would be
with me on this I am it's great I mean
no I anything you want to eat anything
you want to drink vending machines large
water bathrooms there's usually a grassy
area you play fetch with your
seven-year-old you could play cornhole
if you got a mobile set they won't stop
you I've tried that well I don't you
don't want to do anything that's gonna
slow down the trip you got to keep
moving if it's a 12-hour Drive no you
don't want to play cornhole okay every
rest stop but yeah I think you should
stop but for take-out all the time you
say with the rest up because there's no
you just get off and exit and you're
there and then you get back on the exit
there's no like which way do I go I
would
recommend packing special food items and
then instead of stopping to eat having
picnics at rest stops and bring enough
for friends if anybody there are other
people who were there some people are
just are on their last leg at a rest
stop there needs a little fried chicken
I'm not talking about at night let me
just clarify
I thought about day rest stops oh yeah
broad daylight don't go don't go it at
nighttime what what about dancing across
state lines like we did in the mythical
roadtrip I mean we drove all the way
across the country in a u-haul pulling a
minivan I feel like we stopped at every
state line for like it's dangerous and
danced across it it was dangerous I
don't find a parking spot it's on the
side of the road to run back to the
getting out on the interstate and
walking you're just in the danger zone
especially now with texting and driving
like people end up getting into the
shoulder like I like I will not change a
tire if I if I haven't had a flat tire
on the inter so the advice we've given a
day has been so unsafe why can't we just
continue no what I'm saying is if I get
a flat tire on the roadside yeah I'm
calling triple-a man I'm not especially
if it's on the inside if it's on the
towards the road I'm not getting out and
trying to change my tire with the peace
people texting and driving yeah you you
you do have to pull over really far if
you want to but what if here's a wall
what if there's a wall and you can't get
that far over you I'm not getting on
that side of the car because people you
swerve they did their cut they're not
thinking they're there they're not just
texting or driving but people will just
say swerve I'm not I'm not gonna take
that chance I'm gonna make the Triple A
man take that chance
my Popoff when he was uh I don't think
he was the chief of police but he he he
was a policeman before he became the
chief and he pulled he pulled somebody
over just on this side of the Lillington
bridge and he gets it you know the
person pulls over and then he he gets
out of the car and goes back and he's
coming he's talked to the person he's
got their ID and he's coming back to his
patrol car and then he sees this bread
truck coming down
on the road and it's in it's drifting
off of the road and he can tell that
it's not seeing him as he's walking on
the shoulder back to the car he runs
back to his patrol car gets in the car
and slams the door just in time to get
smacked by a freaking Wonder Bread truck
he was he was uh he was hospitalised and
there was no permanent damage I was very
young when this happen but I remember
you know and the stories in retrospect I
did get Wonder Bread for life there was
any any lasting damage but it just goes
yeah even even a flashing patrol car you
know the lights flashing not the whole
car it'd be kind of cool though yeah
he's in dangerous place you don't want
to get on the side of the road so I
can't in good conscience I can't give
that advice to dance across state lines
on the shoulder we did that at our own
risk we don't have anything for Kate
then we haven't got anything rest stops
and in G in the in red alphabet next
alphabet you know that's good advice I
got a I admit Kate that's not very good
you got a jeep just go off-road yeah
that's what you should do you should
drive as the crow flies to wherever
you're going yeah forget the road trip
just make it a trip the 12-hour car ride
is gonna turn into a 14-day Jeep honker
that is an excellent idea you get a map
and you map the straight line as their
crow flies from where you want where you
are and where you want to go and then
you GPS that sucker and then you just
write through people's yards right
through people's pools Xboxes
trampolines this is safe and now you're
giving safe advice it's safe for them
it's not safe for the people in the path
it's not a it's not an armored car you I
mean you get a couple miles I don't even
know she it's just cause it's in the
icon doesn't mean she has it too more I
could go all day man I don't hold back I
got a quick one here from Britney Nora
Nora Nora okay know whare
what are the best summer movies to watch
okay okay I've got a list of five I got
a list of five out the top off your top
that's like that's what the rappers the
freestyler say no no this isn't off the
top I looked at this question and I and
I have my I have my I have my five
movies you know it's wanna see what you
think of it I think these are the five
movies that if you're gonna watch five
movies this summer you got to watch
these five movies all right Hemme there
all summer themed that's that's that's
kind of where I went with this if you
haven't seen him especially Ferris
Bueller's Day Off I should check that
one out my dad watched this with
Shepherd the other day and my dad said I
was watching Ferris Bueller's Day Off
with Shepherd and like seven or eight
times and during the movie he would stop
slap the pillow and say man I love this
kid you tell my Ferris Bueller yeah I
should have invited me yeah haven't seen
it
oh gosh you haven't seen it I know about
it okay well this is your list Goonies
I've seen that I saw it two years ago
okay that's a great summer movie if you
haven't seen that it holds up do the
right thing that's a good summer movie I
have not seen that I and I feel like I
think you would have thought I would
have seen that one because all of the
the soundtrack for that is amazing you
need to go I've watched the sound trying
to go home and watch this tonight do the
right thing out of all these is the one
you do watch the endless summer you've
seen that the surfing movie yeah I I I
think I I know that I've seen it but I
might have fallen asleep it's pretty
soothing movie it's just kind of people
surfing and here's a curveball
summer movie the river wild Meryl Streep
Kevin Bacon
ha tell me that Meryl Streep is not in
that movie I think she is yeah she is
right and Kevin Bacon the river wild I
saw that in the movie theater Oh
with you oh ok for it and I think it's
but you know going back to all the the
river shenanigans from earlier I thought
I think that's why we saw that that's
what she was a river guide and Kevin
Bacon don't say what you can't say
anything about it you can't say what he
is
could you spoil it I don't remember okay
alright he just goes on a trip with him
it's a good movie well you just kind of
you soft spoiled it now everybody's
gonna be watching Kevin Bacon with Eagle
Eye happens pretty early what about a
river runs through it it's not a summer
movie it's just a river movie
what about Cape Fear and it's another
River movie what what about let's talk
more about River movies Lehman name
another rivers name some really good
ones name another river movie Mystic
River Oh River tasia it's the Disney
there's lots of dancing it's animated
river's edge what is river's edge
something that you read off of Feldman's
phone okay last question summers go
summers great man there's a free even if
you're working there's a freedom it's
like the traffic's gone down have you
noticed because of the kids
it's amazing school how much la traffic
goes down in the morning especially I
mean in the afternoon not so much
because but I think the the kids are off
they're out of the their the moms are
out off the streets taking their kids to
school that's I take my kid to school
success Bilan Costa what do I do if I
live in the other side of the world and
it's winter you know that's a good point
we were we've been all excited about
going to Australia we realize it's their
winter
and um well so the answer is you buy
tickets to the tour mythicality aussie
edition we're gonna be in sydney we're
gonna be in brisbane and we're gonna be
in melbourne
yes welcome to gallivanting all around
the place with our family with a
footprint as big as we're gonna have you
probably just how do you running into uh
sir through the roof and yeah that's not
a challenge by the way wait we just want
we want to come see us at the show and
don't try to find us anywhere else tour
mythicality calm seriously if you're in
Australia come on come out I think I'm
bringing this wintertime I think I'm
bringing in warm in I'm bringing a coat
it's not that in Australia it's not that
cold when we're going there in the
winter what what are the temps but I
mean I think 30s 263rd is pretty cold
man it's probably not cold to most
people but it's freezing to me I'm
bringing like a heavy cut I'm bringing a
whole bag that's just full of coats coat
bag okay I'll put my coat in there
that's it that's all the advice that we
have I think there's just so much
freedom with the summer I love it
I love summer man it's great it's your
favorite season
I know fall is my favorite season so
when it's all ending when death is upon
us
yep there's a freshness to fall I feel
like actually it's not a death to me
it's like I don't know it to me is
change is exciting the transitions so
yeah the transitions into every season
of course we don't have that out here in
Los Angeles oh there's a teeny bit but
not nearly the amount of transition that
we got North Carolina that is one thing
that I miss is a transition into fall
and then that first day of spring not
literally the first day of spring but
that when you kind of realize that
spring is happening that's spring is 100
degrees going into spring is a problem
because the pot of the pollen and stuff
pollen and then you go into summer and
it's like it's very it's very smoky and
gloomy out here but then
starts to clear up some late in the fall
we're enjoying it now we're just talking
about the weather
yeah well this podcast sucks all of a
sudden turned into episode of the
Californians we talked about traffic and
weather right oh gosh what all right we
hope you enjoyed this episode of ear
biscuits thank you for all your
questions as we asked you last week if
there's somebody out there that you
think might enjoy summer advice and
podcasts share this ear biscuit with
them if they they might be a parent who
says that we had no need to apologize
their heads with the things we said
about our kids there might be a pregnant
woman with a seven-year-old that they
like to play fetch with I don't know it
might be someone who loves their kids or
likes their kids or just tolerating
their kids everybody on that spectrum is
welcome summer in pregnancy those are
two things that you should not combine
unless if you can help and very
important last thing we want to say is
that after next week's episode we'll be
back with another episode just like
always next week but then we are taking
a short three week summer break because
we just weren't relaxed enough super
cool I know we're taking a short break
we got some other things going on in
kind of preparation for our trip across
the world and then we'll be back July
30th 30th
as a freshman so be three weeks that you
can you can you can mine some older ear
biscuits and lastly I'll just say
continue to give us feedback hashtag ear
biscuits we gave a little speech about
them the morphine of this show in the
last episode we appreciate that feedback
we are processing it and we'll continue
to process as a response to this prompt
hashtag ear biscuits let us know what
you're thinking what did what what
resonates with you what do you
appreciate about the show or about just
about me
just kidding I don't need any feedback
all right thanks for hanging out with us
we'll talk at you next week yes
[Music]